there we go call duty I'm gonna do one
call of duty by myself and then yeah we
can play with you we could actually
would maybe personal comedy yeah all
right I'm watching you on here let's
host you on Twitch alright I'm hosting
your party member - hello
how are we looking we looking good
sounding good are we sounding good are
we looking good and sounding good okay
I'm watching an ad so I'm not sure
what's happening let me see oh yeah you
got a good pass - yeah I got any money
oh good that YouTube Griffin yeah I made
it I made it just the game play bigger
but I got I still got my little pull
like it that's alright
Griffin we play destiny with Steve for
like an hour it was so funny
what was that I know okay writing I had
my xbox
it was super late at night I'm sorry
mm-hmm you know it wasn't like Steve was
on his own account he needs to update it
yeah played on Craig's account all right
that's how it's gonna be okay mother
that's how it's gonna be huh okay okay
son take a prowler I get it tweeting
this out yeah I'm gonna play a quick
stall all that i'ma join these clowns to
see we can win gonna win so a lot of
people up and saying you've been
improving like oh my god well you know
it's tough process it is a process but
I'm learning we under the air base dude
we have to support our friend in need
okay your sound sucks every time you
talk he goes good me know
what's-his-face Alex yeah see every time
he walks
[Music]
hey guys a small donation 30 bucks and
we could help out working headset with
you yeah we need a small donation of 772
dollars - yeah the guy sounds like a
walkie-talkie so the people on my
streamer saying I'm with y'all
yeah Malik Alex team jersey on okay guys
let's go them get a little solo so don't
buy me on my behind you right behind you
I got my new light set up so maybe I
look better I don't know it's just a
ploy we ready to go we got this guy's
sunday fun day tomorrow riffing with
Griffin I got Matt rife from MTV's Wilin
out
that should be dope that should be dope
and all the girls love him so ladies out
there a lot about Craig is in my chat
[ __ ] hugs all nice Jersey God that's why
Craig that's or Craig y'all it's Craig e
waggy-time we go to twitch and see
what's going on in the twitch chat to
your walk you're taking a dump and
watching us play games okay bro TMI but
uh sure
TM I do not need to hear bye you're
[ __ ] okay here we go y'all I'm
always looking for a new intro for my
podcast so if you think you got what it
takes
send it I really like the one I use from
those those two good two dudes it's
really good well they sent another one
that's even better I met the guy came to
the show this weekend one of the guys Oh
for real yeah he's also duh he's also
the what do you call a design guy
detective designs he actually made me a
t-shirt
he made a t-shirt for rifra with Griffin
I have to like get it show you to you I
just don't have any pants on my pics or
it didn't happen that's right guys when
you when you see Griffin flick gaming
with us he's never wearing pants we
don't need your commentary what is this
ESPN shut your face okay blackout here
we go y'all here we go
oh okay I think I want to go to
infiltrate engage and destroy hey what's
up Chris hi Bert [ __ ] I just dropped
early man I don't give up oh we go we go
I'm going oh [ __ ] I don't want to go
there
[ __ ] I don't even know where I'm going
right now
is there anything over here is this even
in the play oh god I'm already [ __ ]
up guys yeah your mics your mapping your
headsets messing up bro oh my god guys
here your head stuck all the way in
there's crackling can you you should
drop again
I knew it saw two guys there the guy
just came in and killed me oh god let's
take it to kill cam real fast kill carry
oh yeah this guy was up here he already
got a gun and they just found me this
guy just can't oh I just got just ate a
nasty bastard man doors opening all
right that was a bad Drive
[Laughter]
oh people still think that the joke that
I'm the guy from the Steve Levy show is
still funny can you imagine that people
still think that's funny god
they do what's going on here
okay
Oh guys go again y'all dropping again
reading deep-dish pizza a nice
i'ma go system it was just a horrendous
drop
solo blackout are you going anywhere
next weekend Griffin no no me in Kansas
City but Kansas City yeah there's the
guest for this week
then you're gonna record with anything
record any I might yes the insider info
did you watch us yet no I haven't seen
it yet I just hit up Bobby
earlier today about watching it with him
him and Steve okay Steve already washed
it with his girlfriend it's a date night
then I'm gonna get to Boyd the Steven
Bobby back on to do but we don't talk
about documentaries our favorite
documentaries okay nice nightmare and in
Neverland you didn't do that
bad guys over here yeah good if it needs
to make a song dedicated dedicated
secret to a there's another team I'm
taking up a zip line to the right
adjacent to us oh [ __ ]
server disconnected what sucks nice it's
annoying
that is annoying
all right I'm just gonna do this one
then yeah then we can play with you dad
or something else then I should play the
Hot Pursuit solo Hot Pursuit Tom's like
she hard I don't cuz you get to read you
get to redeploy I think you redeployed
but there's how they go to guns yeah we
could do that
there's no m'lord the Golden Bear stout
its stabilizer I'll take that
yeah show you a pika today I'm taking
all the good loot damn they had hella
good loot and they didn't utilize it cuz
they suck
I mean they get the twitch chat for a
second sorry twitch chat so Griffin's
new videos dropping tomorrow guys I
think is 9 9 a.m. tomorrow so you guys
you're tuned in Griffin will be there to
you know watch them so long with you
guys and talk [ __ ] to you yeah Griffin
is it any better or cuz I'm not trying
to talk a lot if it's [ __ ] up your
Theor scream oh no that's much better
whatever you did it's a lot better it's
much better now yeah I I just smacked
Mike and I just smacked my thing against
the table a couple of times
fix it up a little bit oh yeah whatever
you just did was terrible I think we're
gonna win this game
Alex I feel it oh you feel it
I can feel it doing well so far
there we go yeah well there's a care
package dropping right next to those
bodies I'm gonna go a little bit zones
on its way though I don't wanna watch
out for that
somebody said turn up the bass we want
to hear you oh man what's going on it
says server just connected again what
the [ __ ] going down yeah I'm not to
quit black out you'll [ __ ] Activision
what is going on you know what maybe
I'll play a little anthem my sound is
low too right now for the same fun okay
I'll raise myself up I know I should
play a little what should I play stream
I'm gonna try this rocket League
I'm gonna try this black ops one more
time but what's a Billy Bob Jim Joe
Jackson Billy Bob Jim Joe Jackson comes
into our chat every [ __ ] stream Billy
Bob Jim Joe Jackson
I don't know what's gone my thumb one
with a mastiff here you're probably
Danielle no I try this again I'm a good
person I know we got to get this call of
duty win y'all I'll just keep trying I
got to get this win there's a Clark runt
Kramer here
Kirk Haku Craver
did you kill that girl the Mastiff no
yes she's [ __ ] dead screaming at a
high rate but it still looks like the
thought doesn't yeah I was out whatever
I'm just trying to stream it ten
something okay let's go to blackout see
if this is gonna work this time - if I
go to play list I'm gonna play a little
i'ma go oh they had this one called
quads hardcore wow what does that one
about we backed up a little bit I'm
gonna go solo this is it I started over
if this [ __ ] doesn't work I'm switching
I said coming in so shitty
that's I got a triple taking stuff out
of we mess them up
hardcore mode assume I said hardcore
mode is trash
alright I mean gonna be on that hardcore
mode the gussy zip line right there man
I like it I'm not using that stupid
elite controller I don't like it banana
I just don't like to paddle things you
know I just got to practice with this
some more
I mean it's nice it feels good I like to
grips and all that stuff but it's just
something funky about the trying to
figure out the paddles like this should
be like this should kill you if you're
in this like steam cuz this is like
pesticide or something I want to fit in
a real game that happens when you're
playing right yeah up top with me I mean
this game looks beautiful I just love
this game oh that's right oh wait this
guy got into a Jeep or something wow
this guy's got inside the house here we
go here we go I gotta shoot people
before I start where is he where's I got
it was outrunning oh he's gone
oh here we go oh there he is
oh yeah in the head oh practice Oh
[ __ ] smooth tough finish me here
look at my chakra aim this all off that
was terrible you see that aim yo where's
where's your body trying to fish he's
punching me he's watching me so I'm
gonna play apex I'm hopefully a
freshwater peacemaker I just want to
play I'm still I'm trying to get this
win in black ops by myself you know
okay I'm not just gonna jump right away
oh you know what I'm gonna try to get to
the boat I'm gonna try to get to the
boat here we go I get to 70 miles an
hour and here we go now God's Idol oh
there's no way I'm gonna make it to the
boat
stealing someone they're ready to ready
we can [ __ ] them up okay I'm not gonna
make it to the boat but I am gonna get
to this area right here oh there's
already [ __ ] here oh my god
dude oh all that and I'm about to die
again
anyway oh my god you guys away uh let's
wait that's wait I got a gun okay come
on I need some shields really bad I hear
I can take this
I know these [ __ ] are over here
I just saw him I got something I got
something else I gotta be aggressive
right now right I gotta be aggressive
yeah yes let's go some of the pathfinder
and someone else down below saw somebody
before I went in God where is he
Darkstar I'll be over here or something
haha this [ __ ] [ __ ] wait for you
to win solo we have day jobs Eric that's
funny
okay I'm here they're up there
are you guys playing with someone else
are you two playing us - we were waiting
okay let's take it as if I'm right
behind you alright I think it's time to
jump into a V X I think I might change
the video to Apex I think it's time for
a pegs I can't with you one more black
ops guys that I'm gonna play a pegs with
them I got two of them I'm gonna go down
here because of that though sucks
die I'm not actually I guess if you get
good god I've been dying right away oh
okay I'm out here in the water pika yeah
the ant dogs pretty good it is pretty
good I gotta be able to get me in time
no I don't think so
oh nice try [ __ ] you weren't doing
really well they're doing real well I
should have just went to go kill the
other team I think I was doing really
good where I could have killed them to
be honest yeah like yeah no you're doing
fine I think it was a tough spot for you
make a choice there I should have looked
for the kill
like look how many kills that I get I
got I only got three one killed but I
did holiday wish I did 834 yeah I was I
was doing like really good for take a
standard you are doing really well
you're doing pika good again Griffin is
too frustrating for me to watch then no
watch go get it [ __ ] yourself you're
gonna do instead
I tried Alex what do you think sure I
went just to kill other people I might
have been able to do it I mean I kill uh
I kept that Bangalore I know I hurt I
hurt that other Pathfinder that was
throwing stuff at us really bad but he
probably kill their teams
I should have healed up all right kind
of panic here we go last one okay I'm
gonna wait a second you know what [ __ ]
it let's go to the [ __ ] in I'm gonna go
to the ship I think I can make you to
the ship hello hey guys you're gonna
pick up some speed here we go here we go
oh my god I'm not gonna make it to the
ship
I'm so not gonna make it to the ship I'm
gonna have to swim well this was
terrible terrible drop let me see if
anybody else is going to the ship oh god
somebody else's Oh No
look oh my god I'm gonna have to okay
this is already terrible I don't even
want to go over there oh my god oh yeah
why am i so terrible at this
Jesus Christ now I have to go to the
beach no gun swimming like a [ __ ]
okay come on all right let's see we can
find
oh isn't that underground [ __ ] over here
that's a name Alex where you at bro oh
my god everybody's already shared ray
there's like zombies or something up
there I'm just [ __ ] running I have
nothing no armor no guns nothing this is
a nightmare
wait I think I am nowhere near the
circle well there's only one person left
in this party no way there's no way
brother what were they talking about I
don't want to talk about it oh I don't
even know they were talking about
California
there's like a car remember that each
remember guys best tacos in Milwaukee
yeah apparently yeah apparently
Milwaukee has the best tacos like yeah
Mexico's only right here you know to me
[Laughter]
the Midwest people oh [ __ ] look there's
a guy right there you see that guy well
that's a zombie oh my god dude there's
zombie right here and I don't have a gun
you can outrun them don't be scared on
me okay you know if you kill them they
drop guns this is great
this is great oh my dude I hate does ah
be that that noise they make it so
[ __ ] scary they're all rude you know
what I mean yeah
wait is this a car you can drive oh [ __ ]
yeah that's a drop-top oh [ __ ] oh my god
I was shooting him oh my god I'll come
out I'm out I'm out I can't I'm done
with this game let's go to apex oh my
god on this hot drop oh my god that's so
ridiculous you see I'm gonna shoot that
guy he's a pal he jumped off his bike
BAM and then he's like ran upon me and
pop out I was dead [ __ ] huh
that was not a good that's alright guys
of course there's no lines for tacos in
Milwaukee
people out here actually have to wait
for lying wait in line for food out here
cuz if the food's really good
[Music]
all right bond cascades here just leave
all right here we go guys
hello all right guys here we go
if you turn off the heater please think
shoot your other Sunday
I can't wait all right are you inviting
me what's the deal here yeah yeah we
invited you oh oh I can't see the
notifications I'd turn them off because
too many people okay yeah I know I know
I know yeah
all right I'm ready this is it
stay frosty my friends well we got to a
game way faster this time
we ready to go team
ready to go ready to go and make sure
you hit that like button guys let's do
this I want to get a win right now
you hear that Alex yeah
this is your champion
[Music]
but on the try-hard pants here a party
right now I always have my heart pants
if and you don't choose it Griffin you
can choose I try our fan state there's
other team that makes you get a gun not
oh here we go
I got a havoc oh [ __ ] I just jumped off
oh [ __ ] there's a lot of shooting going
on man hey guys there's three sets of
blue armor underneath here a body shield
seriously wait yeah you guys should come
take it oh I think I'm one oh no no what
am I talking about
yeah I wanna go do the thing that tells
us where the next zone is yeah skit yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah here we go yard I'm
making my way to go we're making my way
Alex I'm gonna head down towards this
other town here see if we can get some
better loot hey someone in chat said
your YouTube went down let me go check
someone said your YouTube went down
you're live sim-free
i promote other youtubes on our stream
please that'll be your final warning
okay it should be back alright if you're
watching Alex over your performer 3
choice what are you telling him I'm
coming to get it okay
but the stag that [ __ ] dude you know
yeah it's a blue back if you want that I
need a blue background sure oh yeah okay
yeah well well pica took it from you so
I can't remember Pikachu ain't [ __ ]
let's go this way
no those blue backpacks in here oh I
need this I want this oh you guys are
still watching The Walking Dead Oh Mandy
yeah that's too long yeah but who
watching that Wow
tell some people in Coke they need to
really make me make it to soap opera and
the occasional a zombie fight what's up
Sean by the way all right I'm gonna go
to Alex all right let's go
Ravi head towards dawn soon um oh [ __ ]
where are you where are you guys oh
there you are
if the map is so weird like a compass I
wish I can usually get on you get in
these trucks that'll be great
we haven't seen anybody yet that's so
weird these crates are don't open now
they're not so that's a good sign
hmm I need this armor
oh is this feet is this a better gun I
don't you know this is a good gun the
file I uh it's okay what do you have
right now a hemlock in a havoc I would
just keep you have what did you get this
yeah I pop that down you can see what's
in it who's that oh [ __ ] you don't like
to have it people say don't like to have
it we haven't seen anybody can't even
talk did they send you a an actual
physical copy or they gave you like a
code to the game no they're gonna send
me a physical copy I think oh that's
gonna revived in here hmm oh [ __ ]
everybody he's a far ahead of us killers
no Coke right now yeah well at least
he's not dead already
just kidding okay here we go
hey first why can't we get in this tank
this would be tow right
god this tank should be available
or these people that Alex I'm looking
around for him right now
I'd be on the ship oh [ __ ] I can't
believe I just did what I just did
oh it didn't work anyway tells kind of
dope thought I was jumping up just s
sitting here waiting to get shot
basically where I think there's a team
on this ship I'm sure waiting for
movement I saw a guy zipline across that
back thing down there I've lost him
since then
are we gonna stay up here hey we are
team uh yeah we have high ground right
here I like this I don't see anyone I'm
looking I think we well yeah they've
already opened that [ __ ] over there
they've already opened all that so yeah
that's uh let's push out this way let's
head towards this town okay all right
we're leaving Griffin want information
we're all inside the ring
places a link if we play another one
I'll play that Maxine Mexican guy
they're making this definite legend
ethnic legends okay all right this begun
oh there this backpack here and running
around I can't find anybody I know this
is come buddy we're on like there's only
nine squads left 25 people left who [ __ ]
look at that I'm definitely gonna need
that let's see and we're in the circle -
we're in a good spot I still think
there's a team that that's gonna come
from where we were so feelers applying
for us Alex they get a bit cool are you
guys in this tower
yes our what Oh up dear okay how the
[ __ ] you get up there where's everyone
else is hiding there's a ramp Marcy them
up oh cool survey beacon the circle
already - okay I see the team oh shoot
him we're on okay sorry dad
okay hitting them with my wingman we are
you going right as well huh
make sure you smash that like button
guys wait where is it
I don't where were they at if they went
in they went in to the wall wait stop
moving then they'll see us
you stopped moving what if they get a
headshot on you move a little I guess a
little bit's okay want to push him but I
don't want to put us in a bad spot do I
need this oh I do need this okay okay I
gotta get enough ammo
I got enough ammo oh there's only five
squads left we could do this we're
crevice me dirt he's ready okay I fell
off come back up right
hi guys looking at us great uh we're
we're we're we're right here
oh yeah there we're 325 325
Oh cassia okay H I have the ability to
make another zip line where should I
make it don't make it yet we'll hold on
to it
Oh what I should do because if I make it
as a destroy the other one no that stays
forever what if I make a portal here
what's up Zack what's up Zack I jump
down and make a portal and jump up no
cuz I'm no use it is [ __ ] you know
people shouldn't be able to use your
portal that sucks you know I mean yeah
boy like you can make it sniped should
be able to destroy your own zip line
yeah yeah they took a they took in the
balloon brothers
I think I saw someone maybe so out of
zone if they took that balloon oh that's
cool
giving it on that another oh geez not
flying right over us I mean we can go
push the team that's over here now if
you want to go fight and I go for the
care package and I'll take the zipline
back up to us I mean you can but if you
die I'm gonna let I mean let me die okay
let's go some real flame oh right
girlfriend now if you're gonna go go now
don't don't wait too long oh this is
great only 15 be level 12 12 more people
the zipline does it go away or does it
stay no it stays forever I don't like I
got a master think it should go I think
it should go away I got rid of my own
devotion I know what to do I'm gonna
make mine just oh oh hey here's some how
well we can we can all over so we don't
have to but over all of our alts we can
hold on to and save for when we're in an
engagement
I might go to NCR probably not cuz I'm
Pikachu's broke right now when I get the
tax return I'll be good okay there we go
and we need any healing before we into a
fight and we realize that we don't have
healing now I got Phoenix killer Gucci
there's still so many people alive look
how small the circle is the circle still
like this and his 12 people still left
so there's nine people left this is
crazy it's gotta be a team in Bunker oh
wait wait where there's a team or at 20
I'll talk to my driver and see if I can
go to inspire this week we'll see we'll
see
okay just oh [ __ ] how do I get back up
to you guys oh my god you can just write
here Bronx right here Griffin Griffin
jump up here oh I couldn't generate oh
my god you'll be fine oh yeah terrible
jump
[Laughter]
yeah I think there should be fall damage
I don't think you should that'll change
the game Tremayne and like friendly fire
all the time there should be there
should be friendly fire and fall damage
I think oh Jesus dude jeez that's worth
it oh my god because that's because
that's just I play pub G the other day
and I took fall damage that's like
that's not right
yeah what this is so different those
games now there's like no there's like
it seem like differences to all the
games you know what I mean is it's yeah
hey what it's like I I like I still
enjoy pub G but it's so clunky yeah so
yeah and it just doesn't look as
beautiful as these other games man no I
well yeah I know ray it's just like
they've had how long has pubs you've
been out like yeah that's crazy couple
years yeah maybe a year to really
advance that far we're just up here oh I
think we should advance on a time well
let's see what it ring you know what
[ __ ] we're still in the circle [ __ ]
they gotta come to us it's only two from
what I see they jumped off oh [ __ ] what
are you winding okay okay how would I
put my portal where oh my god okay I'm
gonna put a portal here and I want to
jump down okay just be careful down
there
should I go for the care package
[Music]
take Porto
don't take the portal-to-portal I told
you there's someone honest dude
understand how that guy got up there so
fast
he landed I'm pretty sure that's what I
heard I thought he was below us and I
happens I don't get into fights
yeah a sense of security
yeah we were just yeah I agree we were
just sitting around too long we needed
to like get into a battle earlier than
that oh [ __ ] oh god I'm getting dubs I'm
already getting no that's boys here we
go here we go
three games dude I've been I've been
[ __ ] people up let's [ __ ] go is it
because the information or what yeah the
portal mess dude because he was making
fun of it and I'm like you think that's
not a thing [ __ ] but you're
using it without you realizing it like
you're going towards the green circle
dumbass
you know yeah were you talking about
tacos and Milwaukee Oh Griffin
I already got into it about politics and
all kinds of [ __ ] we spend the mountain
hour and a half talking on
I know girl colleges yeah and yeah I
don't
Wow I don't want an electoral college
then [ __ ] you a big word for coke oh boy
fighting words okay there's a team right
next to us just because just just [ __ ]
about itself and I'm a womanizer doesn't
mean that I'm not intelligent to you
first of all two of those things aren't
true okay so you just watch this I'm
gonna put Eric on the groove that's why
I like not having yeah yeah I love like
yeah just give me a moment a weapon
that's so good thank you game all right
here we go
I still look I still have a gun I have a
gun I don't know [ __ ] else picked up
shotgun round from there shotgun next to
it made me feel good there I found him
buzzing become subset Scott in the game
dude that's me I just killed someone so
Gucci extra gun over there extra gun
there's a wingman over here but uh I'll
take I'll take it if you don't want it
you're going on here I need a gun here
has has Copan cow-tipping
I don't think Oh
that have you done that coat oh I
haven't count it what way does that
sound racist pika
he yeah pika picks all the comments that
like would piss you off yeah any Assam
and then he acts like it's not his fault
there could be people in there
complimenting us like wow Griffin is so
funny he's probably one of the greatest
comedians I've ever seen live and
Pikachu let's say he wasn't even [ __ ]
say piece of [ __ ] and I want to fight
him in the street yeah one more one more
baby shower bro baby shower I would have
stayed longer but my friend wanted to go
home Christ who brings their friend to
another personal friend's baby shower pj
right okay well why wouldn't you say
yeah exactly exactly say my friend yeah
the way you said it it was like he
didn't know him was his friend I took it
easy oh now you know how I feel so you
got instigated on it you don't like it
punch to [ __ ] kill a lute take and
got a nice old peacekeeper out of it
good
Alec see that's all so we're going yeah
you're having such a such a good
conversation I didn't want to bring that
up
t-mobile yeah people called Oh started I
just started that's okay I'll take well
we going Austin now I'll join coke and
you can be with pekin Eric yeah
right here okay good we could have done
that I dropped a lot of stuff for you 50
on that Gucci did you go see us he's
gonna watch it later this week with
Bobby
wait I have to like way I have to I
forgot how to poopley
wait I don't have any the shield things
[ __ ] I need hey come here come over here
drop down jump down to me and I'll give
you some a triple charger or a triple
take if you when you get out the body
there's gonna be there's gonna be
shields at your feet that you can take
sweet thank you Amir Amir
oh [ __ ]
but there was like a gold thing in there
there was a gold like something yeah
were you attracted by the gold yeah it's
like a moth to a flame
yeah you know that samurai ki Griffin's
gonna get it for free who's gonna stream
it the company sent the tune oh yeah
yeah they yeah it's the the publicist
for Activision yep are we going to hear
oh yeah let's go again we could win this
we're selling a couple hiccups I'm gonna
need that weighs so much more Abbi pika
I need exhibit you're pulling his weight
and you're over here do you know what
I'm gonna be Gibraltar there's a flame
Craig for going for the gold dude for
going for gold you mean
hey hey whoa hey whoa back off guys
remember we're all making fun of pica
right now
let's go back to that yeah
not like this yeah Pichu
when when comments come up why don't you
ever post any comments or say any
negative comments quickly those give
taken down you can't even see those yeah
since it's some sarcasm reinforcing
positive energy right now yes okay okay
here we go
go for it Singh grab [ __ ] say you got a
peacekeeper okay girl spots get pissed
off oh look at this oh hey hey there's a
body I already have one of those okay
nothing else must be a hot drop - hey
what's going on here
well those are the ships Barb's and
Eggman here oh this guy on the left they
got the left how are you
right here it's you oh [ __ ] I think I'm
the loser guy I forgot I'm not this guy
oh Jesus Christ now we're coming we're
coming just run I'm running
[Music]
I heard someone zipline though someone
zip-lined this guy there's no ammo for
this gun that I have
Jeremy he's here there he is where is he
finished over there go let's go up the
ramen ah yeah
I'm gonna get us some information some
much-needed elevation binary market
people laugh at the information and then
we win they wonder why it's never
finished they don't get it it's cuz we
gotta we hadn't into him
Shinto had it we had it vulgar we had to
entail the team here oh hey recently now
team not tan tan tan yeah going right
here this way how funny would it be if I
was against you guys shooting at you
right now dude I'm not even on site
oh I want a plane I'm on a different
plane should get back with Lindsay
already cuz you're the knight you are an
utter nightmare well just like it this
hemlock this guy has I dropped that
hemlock
there's one more like flying this week
that are not Coke done coke doesn't want
none of this flak right now he doesn't
take you to the finest hour for max I'm
gonna take you the Walmart market okay
there we go
gotta go
there's people hey Blair Oh yep dr.
Bergen shot from a couple different
places dogs
we gotta go was the thing that we're
really important Eric just like listen
to me and not be good basically we're
gonna the ring hey what yeah it was a
good idea at the time was it that one
hey hindsight 20/20 all right hindsight
20/20 of course it was about that go to
die doctor
okay look gonna mark where we're going
we're gonna fly yeah I see is my fault
being Howard um see that little mark
guys he does not sound like Dane Cook
Oh should we stop at the ship right now
all the ships in the way you stop there
you end up having to stop it - [ __ ] wait
is there anything in here no I think
that's where our team came from they had
looted it and then dropped down on us
and we hadn't murdered them
okay we're right in the circle right
here to our body yeah hey Eric you need
shields or no I'm good are you good yep
wait let me see no yeah uh team are in
front of us terrific here pick a front
of you bring babies if one reads rock
there buddy one of them Pathfinder's
goes on you know
hey [ __ ] yeah we killed the whole squad
Oh what he's the only Gibraltar I play
with actually uses his shield I use this
shield all the [ __ ] time
oh my god use it the whole point of
having it use it or lose it
visitor get abused enemy this oh there's
no ammo [ __ ] doesn't have a
shotgun ammo but as far as look at the
map okay I think how much I'm a shotgun
DD I should have done either wholesaler
about it here here take this take this
thickness go oh I should have bought you
know what I have my bomber [ __ ] - if we
get into it if we get into a bad place
just throw your throw your all found it
right on you and then for your shield so
we can just huddle in that
[Music]
yeah yeah it's crazy
you start on racist what what are you
talking about hey there's a whole squad
by me we're not raising racism right
it's like a racist coloring say like
white he has like a white crayon but it
said white privilege
no just said privilege some looted here
somebody somebody in a at the show
brought that for me it's my first time
there I just didn't like the hotel let's
do it the crowd the crowd was fine
Pikachu shut your [ __ ] face oh we
down Minami oh I died with all the
information let's not joke about
information guys information is power
making fun of coke going on right there
yeah we win games I stand by it
[ __ ] information Amal
a permission and and web Weavin I've
been playing a lot I did a lot of anthem
there's another update this week coming
I can't do it what's your what's your
thought on Eric overall it's more
confident yeah just needs more content
I've been actually playing it more now
like right I like how you have to rank
up your character then you play two
different Grandmaster levels that's kind
of fun and then they got some great guns
with great perks like I got this sniper
rifle that if you hit somebody three
times they freeze so it's like some [ __ ]
I never freeze I never never freeze hey
oh jeez and this is just getting really
hurtful now real hurtful we're in the
circle all right four squads left baby
eleven people left so there's eight
people left okay there's an uneven
number of people so that means that this
probably some lone wolf or only two guys
in a team Oh somebody put what's up 160
we be brought me here tomorrow let's go
or you can set a zip line or something I
don't care what you do put on wet Lance
oh you guys are way down here I'm not
taking that creeper a crater I put the
zip line back up top to the tower or no
let's go this way this way this way this
way that's uh see what we can find over
here press mmm
that's right guys new wfe tomorrow we we
what from five minutes yes I'd left
early his second game he was killing it
gets on he's like how do you dump and
I'm like Steve does to a celebrity med
like let me played enough yet you've
played enough
you know what jump is alright alright
guys any pond boat there's just one more
team left so all we got to do is kill
them okay oh yeah yeah oh you're right
ERT yard yeah you sure did cuz now I'm
like nervous no shame at all no it's a
great price trust me I've heard nothing
but good things about game burgoo
unfortunately I haven't got any so sure
I can't tell you personally how great it
is out to your house there's a guy right
there
I'm gonna cut this [ __ ] apparently it's
soy sauce I'm just I'm just saying just
like cuz you might just throw them away
if I get soy sauce packets in the mail I
just gotta tell Laurie goddamn I'm free
okay guys can you focus there's only two
squads left a biggest dude Eric are we
one of the song list are weat way some
sites no sites no sites in it know my
place
know what comic strip above peace peace
is he just shot eight bullets into the
air to get serious about it direct
attention to our position of course you
are I'm coming I think they're they've
gone oh they got somebody back everyone
give me energy
[Laughter]
I'm gonna die
my god run just run this run if you guys
will get to be you can but they're gonna
rush you yeah off the banana I'm right
behind you
she'll come in the she'll die right next
to you oh my god your run-outs or
something haven't they're coming
come on I thought that was sergeant
Walter here what
oh wait that's ours yeah was ours I just
I just [ __ ] fired it off I did
exactly what you said to do did three
dude three three of his bombardments
landed right on my spot in a row
let's forget unlucky second place is
game is his game review usda-approved it
might not be it's an important factor
out there remember guys if you want to
support Griffin Annie you can go to w uh
you can go to game rikku calm and I
check out you can use a code wfe goo ah
w fe goo some money off w fe goo
but I'm the Craig did he just decide not
to get on Craig's coming guys he's
alright I gotta grab something I'll be
right back wait wait let me get us going
alright well I'm still here all right
should i sundar said now or we gotta
move
I got a shoe we got a $2 wait damn I'm
telling you I don't understand why this
dream
we drop you oh god sorry go change the
own quality for yourself or you're
looking at the source on your laptop on
your broadcasting do you know I'm
looking at like oh my I'm onto you -
because that's how you look at the chat
you know what I mean yeah it seemed like
this okay there we got refreshed
sometimes it's sometimes the YouTube
that we have with on the settings in
Auto wait what the [ __ ] oh man we just
landed with somebody that has a gun dude
and he's [ __ ] killing me right now
yeah we landed shots we literally live
oh that was terrible that was terrible
oh god dammit dude hey Landon got the
guns that's that's the line on zombies
he's got me warmer they've landed a lot
getting lucky we know he's here oh dude
how many times the amount of times where
I've dropped first and not been able to
pick up the gun in that other guy just
comes in and sweeps them all up I know
it's [ __ ] brother brother man okay
let's go let's go get some information
there's some persons being sarcastic or
not Griffen gaming is so clean audio and
video I mean is that's gonna [ __ ]
kill me
yeah god dammit dude that grenade [ __ ]
me up oh wait sorry
there's about me killed me [ __ ]
grenade dude I'm a psycho [ __ ] I
had that whole [ __ ] squad
nice no killers should wait for them and
turn my voice down
don't worry this one sir my chat that
his Falls are dropping and he does like
girls and he does get excited when he
sees boobs so he's got a letter song for
news you know when you touch them for us
and it feels like a baggage and
alright come on let's get this victory
all right for this thing it first to get
victory here I need the land to find a
gold wingman and purple armor then I'll
walk around this whole area we're gonna
wait for these guests cuz I want to drop
where they dropped I'm gonna [ __ ]
shut up I'm gonna I'm gonna show you
what real information is to do this son
here we go just landed and somebody's
already dead
oh [ __ ] the guy here reloading right now
watch out he's in the room be careful
which right there why would you do it
great I'm faster than you
cuz I'm life for you you shoot better
than I would've died if someone's
shooting outside Griffon move what in
healing dude I only have 12 rounds in
this gun I don't even have this is just
this is more action we've seen in an
hour
oh my god there's a guy here shooting me
from across the way
I can't do a Z that was crammed it
that's all pikas fault oh my god oh my
god like we had that gum that was pika
pika let's draw master there that was
good actually no I was not a job bastard
that was you know well you know when I
ready okay
that was great are we gonna try to Mel I
mean you've gotta get out same game yeah
we're try them yeah okay
Cooke you ready three yeah one you're
looking for it ready okay we just don't
know we got it already bro wait oh wait
okay no I'm just going in lead never
mind
hey you're going in Elena I've already
yet we'll figure out we're in the same
game for sure if there's a champion at
the same champion squad ah that's how
you feel good job good job
I'm thinking I'm thinking deep I have
the info this is coach should be worried
already trash like four games ago I'm
too beer steep about to be number three
dude this one I play the best duty
no not no fear of your alcohol
consumption your - now yours deep god
help us - beers deep alright what do you
uh I'm a CD - yeah I don't think we're
the same game okay we'll go there
hypothetically for you I'll go [ __ ]
let's go [ __ ] okay I'm nervous I'm gonna
throw a shield right away when we get to
the ship
yeah this could be dangerous pika
Angelica
yeah hey I got a gun bro that's no
excuse I was a [ __ ] shield I could oh
my god the chat wants to know what does
coke think of what new doesn't care guys
yeah yeah oh there's some nudes of a
fighter I'm all about news of a female
fighter so we could see her ball I think
I think she did it on purpose
of course you know how hard it yeah yeah
come on
she definitely that's all pub right
there that's fine
do you girl yeah you see how the
California avocados are being recalled
yeah all the nudie pictures nipple
avocados they're both they're both
squishy
[Laughter]
Alex let's go information good rushing
me I'm coming all I have is trash I'm a
wingman an alternator here comes another
one
also I made econ her name is Misha like
Kesha Kesha tastes are you looking at
the twitch chat
because I have it on me like no knob
just cuz I was on my YouTube Twitter
channel so I wasn't you know thanks for
watching anyway how many people are
watching on YouTube 125 yeah I am I am
jumpmaster oh watch out oh yeah because
you're supposed to stay with us piece of
[ __ ] god that's with you were with you I
got a gun oh my god there's no gun okay
I have a gun Oh what because the one
person with a guns down okay I have a
gun where are you thank you how are you
down already
you still he's kicking me I don't know
where he is
oh they're up here you got them I'm
gonna drop down there's another person
coming there's a Bangalore coming down
straight running oh you got him down oh
my god I can't believe it
that was worried it's not almost [ __ ]
great oh hey visitor I don't know how we
survived that you're trying to go any
now one day Griffin living on Alex wait
wait up top up top coke of top-left side
oh he has a wingman fortunate
unfortunately the team up here still
yeah no worries get an armor first bro
cause you're gonna die dude out there's
no armors to find man okay wait look up
box are you damn yeah there's a team
there pika heard them
it's way by getting the last one
one circle also you ready I can't
believe we survived that little I'm
still in shock about that survival a
good player no we're playing with a gem
so hurt did like try to walk towards
somebody this like a team place
[ __ ] but I can if you can get
there dude it's a law yeah that's way
too far there's no I'm not gonna do this
dude how close are you coke to get down
your game we're going I'm [ __ ]
wrecking shop right now but keep it keep
it all together that sounds unlikely yes
I do you think that pika some pikas
following in your footsteps he's been
using a lot of Pathfinder recently no
I'm just in are you serious I'm doing
the battle pass thing oh he's doing so
good have any information if you don't
got the info link in the wind there you
go it's just a new thing that gets on
your side on my good side yeah you're
really easy then
pika getting the Intel hey guys you want
to get to cook sorry snack info pika
Intel
yeah you're creating a month this he's
not a [ __ ] sticking answer it that's a
massager I don't think that's a massager
your thing is blank yeah I think it's I
think it's kind of inside kick me into
dashboard here there we go
no yeah it just said can actually the
server timed out - we'll leave you guys
yeah you could do it you guys ok phrase
you guys still you [ __ ] I have faith
are you at oh wait I still gotta get
over that these people have really this
games so full house and killed gotta
have we're just getting out of the game
is that what we're doing yeah you get
out of this [ __ ] hold the start button
and then click leave match Oh
it's not working oh my god we'll start
bottom hold it what is happening right
now it's just say something what if I
guess Alexa say that is maybe next time
you go down you can ask Cortana for a
rebuff where you go to artillery and
swim from that way I'm gonna know
somebody's uh get somebody up there I'm
gonna create a zip line to go up to this
thing right here up top Namita oh my god
it's a nightmare
grab some loot it's a marma at least oh
I'm coming to your class information
information has now got we got bottom
copy copy move to relay we got that
information bro
and I know we got it you have to call me
I'm dragon wagon call me Nighthawk
circles coming lion lesson I heard that
I felt my dinosaur
all right here we go
let's make an effort pika make up a
little bit of an effort here you don't
get to count my nightmares [ __ ] tickers
up to 14 this chat is the worst maybe
like over here maybe we need to fear off
the like yeah yeah yeah let's go there
tire we're here I guess it's time yeah
we have to just go here here I'm done
ready let's do this yes I'm also gonna
Eddie ready live action let's go live
action oh [ __ ] you almost got blasts up
someone's there fire would be a
nightmare killing people
IV [ __ ] Dennis what's zipline I want
to killed you like three times we got
our 301 here decent gun
I already got a hemlock so Peacekeeper
over here first blood hit one brother
there's another one though all right get
back get back get back it's not [ __ ]
with heading towards airbase guys
towards got a retreat retreat somebody
there's a lot of gunfire going on and
that's I'm attracted to it
excuse me isn't this apply follow me I'm
coming just behind you [ __ ]
I need guns damn it
you just need you too sir there's one
guy on you're following yeah slide skip
yes what's that this was death over here
man what was that about
there's some serious I'm serious went to
town in this place now we're just
picking up the benefits right here all
right there we got them fight so let's
let's keep that let's keep them fighting
I like that yeah like this was a war
zone there's like six crates over here
sounds a me I mean oh [ __ ] shouldn't I
see me it's on top of that for my shield
just left here push the left and push
left when you can you guys see where I'm
tender guy upstairs yeah we're we're in
the ring yeah they're probably going for
that care package so how did that not
work yep yep yep there right there okay
thank you okay smite up this rank in
this guy I'm with you I'm with you yeah
by the way shut up going to this
hospital me oh I thought I could figure
out how to climb [ __ ] and I felt well
here we go
I missed a purple helmet I'm sorry chat
thanks for letting me know
thank so much chasing after not on the
roof anymore with you you took the jump
heads oh [ __ ]
you separate teams in there get me dicks
out in every gunfight six down every
gunfight
there's one here hey what's up what's up
Michael hey crave more there we go
someone's coming can I use all four pegs
use all four pegs gonna see Eric in the
back just not moving just jumping when
he should be running nope he's trying to
use the old knockdown shield Oh why just
feels different
Oh coming Erich Koch here we got me Alex
careful okay I'm looting Craig's not
here right now yelling fight it out
inside this is gonna be a good fight
[Applause]
i'ma stay with this guy I like this guy
I don't even have enough money to get
the Mexican dude
I kinda need em oh I don't know if you
have money for Mecca I only have eight
kills and discard you have 200 kill
Bruce Kenner how'd that guy win a game
look out for the windows stay hidden
took too long dude there's all these few
teams going there three teams you know
what I'm doing I'm breaking off let's go
over here to the left we were in the
same place damn gun oh my god oh my god
the elite controller is killing me right
now I can't even pick it up I'm dying
this is ex got it got it got it the same
thing as a regular controller no it's
not amusing he's [ __ ] paddles don't
use the paddles you don't use all of
them I know but I can't I forgot which
one was which
so like I'm jumping this [ __ ] sliding
there's one outside I don't have a gun
but I have alright
no he's my right should I see some [ __ ]
down right here
any team right there I just went down
there my regular ex president won't work
unfortunate situation with the flatline
into single fire every room I'll front
weight to my left
you must knew that you could put the
final to a fire I did not know that but
now I know well tell you what I know is
I still don't have a gun doesn't make
things harder for you above us the punch
is so stupid on this game the animation
it's like now they're getting a fight
let them fight I'll come jumping down
here so I don't have a gun
yeah fall Eric fall Eric it's a good
idea fall Eric right now alright he's as
crazy my eardrums
[Music]
then it was traffic I'm gonna go back to
the girls give you [ __ ] I need to be
able to like teleport okay okay vulgar
where yet don't pick up a gun winners
don't need a gun oh they saw me they're
fighting somebody else yeah them fight
it out sure what was that from is the
mobile is the mobile apex gonna be
connected to to this one
maybe that's such a distance film down
swing out the bottom door let them come
down all right coming it's wholly
outside the doors the guy right now I'm
lifeline who African lifeline look at
the pain don't move yet oh [ __ ] we gotta
go
oh they're just all right there yep yeah
yeah off surrounded apex mobile aisle
[Music]
hey what's up which people do you got
your cell 45 yep well show you go Alex
what are you thinking oh my god long-ass
game long as one we've done four games
and why you guys have a cell-free life I
know that's - where are we going oh I
see
way over there we're not gonna make that
you already are okay
this isn't anywhere from anywhere I
think we'll do a beer you know sometimes
I know I'm such a slow loser everybody's
I'm a slow looter
like I'm like I'm at the mall and I'm
browsing like I'm at a flea market yeah
about a flea market the food court yeah
that's one of the notes people have for
me all the time
loot faster you just appreciate the loot
more than others no you didn't miss the
first win we haven't won yet tonight
we got second people there
you got this Alex done nothing McCreary
and uh Dave I'm just keeping a positive
mental attitude that's all I need to do
what I that's what I do man everything
always works out well sometimes stop
I'll tell you what I won't have a
positive attitude so long I don't kill
me with shotgun shots
pull back I feel like sometimes it works
yeah your favorite food that won't delay
is what's Griffin's favorite food I like
Thai food sushi would be if had to pick
it'll be sushi I got a good sushi food
like koi or Nobu they get like a good
like like an ass
come on me I'm like I'm Chile Chilean
sea bass whoa si si I'm telling you
information brother wait what oh he's
down there what he good I'm down folks
but why are you all the way down
I like it I was jumping over this
stairway and shot me as I was jumping on
this daily this a hot dropping or is
this just a regular guy here if you
wanna came in you would have been able
to kill this guy oh my god that's gonna
be it for me cuz somebody's on my door
so I gotta go thanks for watching stream
for people that are watching me I
appreciate you I know I gotta go 10 a.m.
tomorrow I'll be live chatting with my
new episode love you guys and Griffin
gaming Oh